[Música]
todo mundo sonha com alguma coisa que
ainda não conseguiu alcançar a casa
própria um relacionamento saudável qual
o teu sonho da casa própria um
relacionamento saudável ao teu sonho
imagino que quando criança nossos sonhos
são extremamente grande e imaginamos
assim foi comigo pelo menos que conforme
vamos crescendo os sonhos vai se tornar
realidade automaticamente
mas acontece que entre sonhar e realizar
existe uma grande um grande espaço
imagina quantos sonhos morrem dentro das
comunidades do brasil e do mundo por
falta de oportunidade mas não somente no
brasil ou nas comunidades
imagina quantos sonhos permitimos que
morremos dentro da nossa vida
por conta de todas as dificuldades por
conta de todas as burocracias que
presenciamos ao longo do dia a dia eu
pergunto a vocês o que vocês fariam para
realizar os sonhos que ainda talvez não
vivenciaram grande parte das pessoas
fariam eu farei de tudo mas imagina que
esse eu faria de tudo para algumas
pessoas e se tudo é quase nada
para algumas pessoas e se tudo é quase
nada
eu cresci vendo o meu pai chegando em
casa bêbado gastando todo o dinheiro até
para dar comida em casa nicky e vários
tipos de jogos e vícios agressão verbal
e física era normal assim era frequente
dentro do dentro dentro da minha casa
eles agrediam acreditando que aquilo era
a educação porque depois de um certo
tempo eu escutei o que a minha mãe
falava quando ela tinha 13 anos
trabalhando na enxada lá em minas porque
os primeiros três filhos do meu avô
nos primeiros três filhos eram mulheres
minha mãe outras duas tia e não tinha
conversa é para trabalhar na enxada e
minha mãe trabalhou na enxada e minha
mãe contando que
quando acontecia alguma coisa eu batia
nela com o cabo da enxada e lacre ele
acreditava que aquilo era educação
meus pais me agrediram porque eles
culturalmente entender o que a agressão
ela é a educação mas como que nós vamos
deixar com que a agressão vencer
confundida com a educação
muitos pais agridem seus filhos porque
assim os seus a no caso os pais deles os
avós agrediam dizendo que aquilo era a
educação quanto os pais agridem seus
filhos pensando que isso é o certo
quantas coisas estamos fazendo no dia a
dia sem pensar só repetindo reagindo e
refazendo e mantendo uma cultura e e uma
certa consequências na sociedade
a pergunta que me faço e faço a vocês é
quem educa o educador
quem educa o educador quem facilita a
ruptura do círculo vicioso gerador de
sofrimento que se mantém por via da
ignorância também a época que estudava
na escola no bairro onde eu moro
entre 1999 e 2009
durante dez anos se manteve com a taxa
de homicídio acima da média nacional
enquanto em 2001 morria 27 na média
nacional no município onde eu morava no
rio 84 pessoas a cada 100 mil habitantes
eu cresci vendo com muita freqüência com
muita freqüência as pessoas morrendo
naquele lugar
eu me recordo que com um aproximadamente
pouca idade pouca idade mesmo eu tinha
retornado da escola e aí era muito fácil
distinguir o que era tiro que era rojão
e eu escutei tiro eu corri até a frente
do portão quando eu olho na frente do
portão tinha um jovem morto todo furado
de bala a rua ela ela ainda era de terra
e o sangue de 2 corria o sangue dele só
acaba na terra eu vi isso com muita
freqüência eu vi isso com muita com
muita
com muita freqüência realmente na escola
também era muita violência professores
que não sabiam ltda e não não incluíam
que era diferente eu escutava na minha
casa se apanhar na rua vai para a escola
se apanhar na rua vai apanhar em casa
também
então imagina na mente de um joga o tipo
de instrução que eu tive eu era uma
criança violenta um jovem violento e na
escola eu eu colocava pra pra fora
aquela violência que eu vivia dentro do
meu lar
aquela violência que sem pensar os meus
pais reproduziam comigo porque os pais
deles reproduziu reproduziram com eles
ea pergunta mais uma vez eu faço que
tipo de ação que você reproduz sem
pensar na consequência é um tipo de
pergunta com nove anos de idade os vende
alface couve nas ruas do bairro com 11
anos de idade
eu sou dava sem bijuterias para ganhar 2
50 um outro município
sabe aquele troco que você deixa por um
garçom ou por um manobrista acredite
esse era o meu pagamento aconteceu uma
coisa quando eu tinha 13 anos que aí era
o momento da formatura da 8ª série e
teve nesse momento um certo delay um
certo desconforto porque os meus pais na
hora de comprar calça preta camisa
branca pensaram o que o que você vai
fazer com essa roupa depois da formatura
e aí meu pai com 13 anos me colocou para
entregar panfleto da praça de embu onde
moro e eu comecei entregar panfleto por
um restaurante então para trabalhar de
garçom foi um pulo porque a roupa eu
tinha e rapidamente obviamente conseguir
rápido trabalhar de garçom 13 14 15 e 16
anos eu trabalhei muitas horas
eu me recordo que eu voltava pra casa às
vezes 11 horas quase meia noite já não
tinha um transporte público eu voltava
de a pé e olhava as pessoas que em
outras outros jovens assim se divertindo
andando de moto e e vestindo as roupas
que eu gostaria de vestir
fazendo coisas que eu gostaria estava
trabalhando então até os 16 eu trabalhei
muito eu comecei realmente trabalhei
muito nesse tempo na minha vida eu
sempre acreditei na minha vida eu sempre
desejei ser uma pessoa melhor
mas eu acreditava que ser melhor ela ter
mais dinheiro
agora vocês imaginam no bairro onde eu
morava onde moro as pessoas que tinham
dinheiro das pessoas que tinham ações na
criminalidade
então eu fui me deixando influenciar por
aquela realidade porque o tênis que eu
queria vestir as pessoas do tráfico do
roubo que tinham a roupa que eu queria
comida que eu queria essa era as pessoas
ou seja os modelos de liderança que ouvi
na minha juventude na minha infância não
foram modelos de revista não foram
modelos de pessoas que foram
empreendedoras que transformaram que
criar um aplicativo que criaram que
escreveram livros dão às pessoas que
eram os meu as pessoas que eu me
inspirava ou era literalmente as pessoas
que estavam ali no tráfico porque eles
tinham que o que eu gostaria de ter
eu acreditava que ser uma pessoa melhor
era ter mais dinheiro eu acreditei que o
dinheiro ele era o único valor porque
assim foi acontecendo com minha vida eu
fui percebendo isso logo com 16 anos eu
peguei uma parte do meu pagamento
trabalhando de garçom comprei uma
quantidade de droga e foi vendendo a
festas nas festas nas baladas imagina né
todos vocês certamente frequentam ou já
frequentaram vão frequentar festas e
sabem com muita clareza como que é o
ambiente das festas eu cheguei aqui
lugar e eu vi que uma outra forma de
ganhar dinheiro
jovem comecei a vender droga na balada
isso foi tomando uma proporção deixou de
ser uma aventura foi tomando uma
proporção uma intensidade e aí vocês já
imaginaram o que pode ter acontecido eu
criei a ilusão que pelo caminho mais
fácil para que eu pudesse ter dinheiro
no bolso seria o melhor a fazer seria o
que eu podia fazer
como vocês podem imaginar
eu fui parar na prisão com
de nove anos de idade diferente de
muitos que às vezes quando começam 15
muitos que começam a se envolver com
algum tipo de situação ea família
percebe que isso vai dar ruim isso vai
dar
vai gerar conseqüências e manda pra
fazer uma viagem no exterior
manda pra um curso de férias vai fazer
um sei lá uma meditação alguma coisa não
tipo eu não tive esses espaços para
refletir fui vivendo eu fui buscando
aquilo que a sociedade me cobrava ter o
dinheiro e eu fui eu percebi que eu fui
abraçando as oportunidades que tinha o
meu redor e eu eu eu fui pro crime eu
fui vender droga nas festas as pessoas
se divertindo e eu estou vendendo todo
ganhando enfim eu imaginei que cleusa o
que pelo caminho mais fácil era ser uma
pessoa melhor
na prisão com 19 anos quando eu cheguei
eu vi literalmente como era fácil morrer
naquele lugar
eu vi pessoas que por não suportar
aquela aquela aquele estado de de
situação àquela que o estado deplorável
vi várias pessoas no estado que ela não
tinha o brilho no olho de vontade de
sonhar em vários outros momentos antes
falharam com ela e elas falharam também
e chegaram na prisão eu vi como era
fácil perder a vida vem pessoa viu uma
vez um cara que ele pulou
não sei o que passa na mente dele mas
ele pulou do segundo andar vocês podem
ver nessa foto ele pulou no segundo
andar e aí olhava aquilo como era fácil
morrer naquele lugar e eu pensava comigo
se eu morrer aqui como um que as pessoas
vão lembrar de mim eu faço essa pergunta
pra vocês agora se vocês morrer com base
nas ações nessas nas escolhas nas
atitudes de cada um de vocês como que as
pessoas vão lembrar de vocês quando
vocês morrerem tipo de lembrança vocês
vão deixar esse foi um dos pensamentos
que eu tive quando estava na prisão como
que eu vou como que eu vou ser lembrado
se eu morrer nesse lugar uma pessoa ela
nunca vai sozinha prisão sua família foi
presa junto era muito e nem acreditava
eu ver como que o semblante de tristeza
vem da minha mãe e do meu pai tendo que
carlos na frente de pessoas estranhas
para visitar isso foi uma demonstração
de amor que até então fez com que eu
literalmente tivesse ressignificar essa
história de agressões com meus parques
porque os meus pais chegaram para com a
minha vida eu fui eu desejei saber mais
sobre eles
não sou mandela ele disse que ninguém
conhece uma prisão
ninguém conhece uma nação antes de
conhecer então as suas prisões e uma
nação ela não deve ser julgada com base
de como ela tratam os seus cidadões mais
requintados mas sim como ela tratam seus
cidadãos mas simplórios enfim esse vídeo
mostra uma cela de prisão com mais de 25
pessoas presas não sei se vocês chegaram
a ver um vídeo com realidade virtual que
mostra o interior de uma cela e esse
vídeo tive oportunidade de detalhar
contando a minha história nesse vídeo
hoje do brasil tem mais de 700 mil
pessoas presas é a terceira maior
população prisional do mundo nos últimos
40 anos nós temos prendido pessoas
acreditando que prender pessoas resolve
o a questão da insegurança pública
mas como que você vai excluir alguém
colocar num estado de extrema extrema
dificuldade para você ter uma idéia em
alguns momentos eu eu colocava metade da
coberta no chão ea outra metade eu me
cobri o travesseiro é o chinelo pense a
idéia de que isso vai fazer com que
aqueles que foram para a prisão bem a
voltar de uma forma interessante
pensante isso não acontece
enquanto a sociedade ela se mantém com
as portas fechadas para o trabalho e
outras várias coisas o crime ele nunca
fecha as portas
o crime ele não fecha as portas isso é
que faz com que literalmente as pessoas
acabam retornando para a vida do crime
eu dentro da prisão eu percebi que seria
muito fácil repetir aquela história
infinitas vezes seria muito fácil viver
aquela rotina saindo e voltando
infinitas vezes acontece que eu vi que
eu só estava naquele lugar porque eu
preciso eu eu não dei crédito à educação
e aí eu vi a educação como uma grande
saída dentro da prisão eu li mais de 150
livros
boa parte desses livros eram
de psicologia e nesses livros eu li uma
frase que dizia que a educação é a arma
mais poderosa para mudar o mundo
quem acredita nisso pode levantar bom
junto comigo eu percebi eu vi como que a
educação transformou a minha vida
literalmente isso foi muito importante
para minha vida porque me deu a condição
de pensar como eu poderia fazer alguma
coisa para mudar aquela situação e eu
comecei realmente observar como que o
amor da família era muito importante e
poderia literalmente fazer com que eu me
apegar se em algo mais positivo a
educação é a saída pra para as questões
que levam à criminalidade
eu percebi que literalmente eu tava
vivendo aquela situação porque eu não
tinha uma boa educação tendo passado
pela prisão ainda com todo aquele estado
de dificuldade com toda aquela situação
caótica que me motivava se manter no
crime
eu percebi que eu poderia fazer alguma
coisa diferente eu saí da prisão entre
no curso de psicologia terminei o curso
de psicologia pi mediação de conflitos
direito penal e criminologia e resolvi
criar reflexões e liberdade que leva
cultura de paz e desenvolve competências
emocionais compartilham valores humanos
dentro das escolas dentro das prisões e
dentro das empresas
porque o que eu percebo que mais nos
falta é um é o real contato com os
valores humanos
muitas pessoas acabam vivendo
conseqüências acabam colocando a sua
vida o potencial da sua vida perder
porque não conhece a esperança não
conhece o respeito não conhece eu só não
fiz melhor da minha vida logo no início
porque eu não conhecia eu acredito que
quanto mais valores humanos cada um de
nós compartilhar cada um de nós se
apropriar nós vamos literalmente
conseguir mudar o estado de realidade eu
acredito que nós precisamos e podemos
superar o preconceito que nos ensinaram
a ter e fazer com que aquele que hoje é
fazer com que aqueles que nós aprendemos
a chamar de favelado ex-detento aquele
que nós destinamos nosso preconceito
vencer incluído vencer parte de uma
sociedade transformadora esse não é um
sonho apenas meu eu vi o que a educação
e os valores humanos fez na minha vida
esse pode ser um sonho
coletiva esse pode ser o nosso sonho eu
convido literalmente que esse seja o
nosso só eu sonho de compartilhar
valores humanos prisão não é justiça e
educação de qualidade
sim por mais que o crime convidava por
mais que as portas be se manteve fechada
eu sonhei
eu busquei algo melhor pra minha vida eu
encontrei pessoas que estenderam as mãos
pra mim eu encontrei pessoas que me
mostraram algo diferente de tudo aquilo
que ouvi e eu desejei então som em
compartilhar valores humanos
eu acredito que nós juntos literalmente
podemos fazer transformações que
realmente o mundo ea sociedade precisa
viver
nós temos que se libertar da prisão
psicológica da prisão do preconceito é
uma grande satisfação e oportunidade de
compartilhar suas palavras com vocês
mais uma vez muito obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]